House of the Dragon has plenty of dark scenes,
but this part of Episode 7 may be the
darkest – literally. And that's the
least controversial thing about this season
that has fans up in arms. Spoilers ahead!
House of the Dragon Episode 1, "The
Heirs of the Dragon," revolves around
a tournament heralding the birth of the
new prince. Viserys is sure it'll be a boy,
while Queen Aemma just wants an
end to her miserable pregnancy.
Her labor is intercut with the tourney.
The knights smash each other's faces,
but the real horror unfolds in Aemma's bedroom.
The maesters tell Viserys that they cannot save
Aemma, but they may yet save the child. It's
upsetting enough that Viserys is given control
over Aemma's body. It's worse still that he can't
bring himself to tell her the truth. Aemma suffers
excruciating pain and panic as the maesters
not-so-carefully slice her open and pull the
infant from her womb. She dies moments later, and
baby Baelon perishes before the day is through.
Some viewers felt the episode should've had a
trigger warning, and many lamented that the Game
of Thrones universe was still torturing
and disposing of women for shock value.
We meet Daemon's mistress, Mysaria, in
"The Heirs of the Dragon," then get to
know her better in Episode 2, "The Rogue
Prince." Daemon steals a dragon egg and
takes off for Dragonstone on Caraxes
with the supposedly pregnant Mysaria.
Otto and the Kingsguard arrive
to negotiate his surrender.
"Welcome to Dragonstone, Otto."
But Rhaenyra and Syrax have everything
under control. She lands her dragon,
de-escalates the situation, and recovers
the egg. It turns out Mysaria isn't really
with child, and she's not happy to
have been used in Daemon's scheme.
"I have been sold as property
more times than I care to count.
Beginning in a homeland I can no longer recall."
Viewers were fine with the story. They
just couldn't wrap their heads around
Mysaria's accent. As Fire & Blood details,
Mysaria is a dancer from Lys who's smarter
and more capable than most people assume.
But the choice of accent exoticizes her
and is simply difficult to understand. No one
else from this region of George R.R. Martin's
world sounds this way. Nor does actress Sonoya
Mizuno, who was raised in Somerset, England.
As if pimping out his daughter weren't bad enough,
Otto Hightower takes things even further
in Episode 3, "Second of his Name."
As soon as Alicent gives birth to little
Aegon, Otto begins scheming to put his
grandson on the Iron Throne. This episode
follows a hunt held to celebrate the boy's
second birthday. The Hand uses the opportunity
to sway Viserys with tradition and symbols.
"I've never been one for signs
and portents, your Grace, but
if the gods did wish to show their favor."
But when he doesn't seem to be getting anywhere,
he changes tactics. Princess Rhaenyra
is still in need of a husband.
"You must marry."
When Viserys vents about the
political problems this presents,
Otto suggests that perhaps the two-year-old
Prince Aegon and the 17-year-old Princess
Rhaenyra could marry each other. The Targaryen
king, with his long family history of incest,
balks at the idea. Besides, even
though he's 15 years her junior,
we wouldn't want to inflict Aegon's
depravity and abuse on poor Rhaenyra.
Episode 4 of House of the Dragon, "King of
the Narrow Sea," is among the most salacious
hours of television set in Westeros so far.
Rhaenyra very nearly hooks up with her uncle
Daemon before she coerces her employee
and sworn protector, Ser Criston Cole,
into bed. Then, she swears on her dead mother
that what we just saw happen didn't really
happen. But for all Rhaenyra's wildness, viewers
found another sex scene harder to stomach.
Alicent is settling in for the night
when a servant interrupts her peace.
"Pardon me, Your Grace. The king
has requested your presence."
This is an order and not an offer. As
Rhaenyra is enjoying sowing her oats,
Alicent lies still and expressionless
underneath the king, who is, as fans
pointed out, visibly ill. Not even the queen
of the Seven Kingdoms rules her own body.
Otto Hightower might be the force behind the
Greens' treachery, but Ser Criston Cole — who
carries out most of Hightower's schemes — might go
down as the most hated character on House of the
Dragon. After their dalliance, Criston asks
Rhaenyra to run away with him. She refuses,
but doesn't exactly reject him, merely
explaining she must fulfill her duties as heir.
"I am the crown, Ser Criston. Or I will be."
It soon becomes clear that Criston never loved
Rhaenyra. He's an insecure, possessive hypocrite
with the shortest-ever fuse and the longest-ever
grudges, which makes fans absolutely loathe him.
At the feast to kick off Rhaenyra's wedding to
Laenor Velaryon, the groom's not-entirely-secret
boyfriend, Joffrey, susses out that the princess
and her sworn protector must be sleeping together.
"I know who it is."
"Who?"
"The handsome paramour."
Joffrey doesn't realize their
relationship is past tense,
so when he approaches Ser Criston to form an
alliance, he's tragically unprepared for the
knight's extreme overreaction. As the gathered
wedding guests take to dancing, Criston knocks
Joffrey to the floor, then beats him until
his face is pulverized beyond recognition.
We don't know what, precisely, Criston's
motivation is. He might be worried word
of his broken vows of chastity will get out, or
perhaps he's simply spiteful. Whatever the reason,
fans find this vicious murder abominable.
Joffrey and Laenor appear to have a healthy,
loving partnership. To many, including
The Advocate, Joffrey's murder feels
like a particularly egregious example of
media's tendency to kill off gay characters.
Healthy relationships are rare in Westeros, so
when fans miss an opportunity to see one unfold,
they get upset. Harwin Strong doesn't
get many lines prior to Episode 6,
"The Princess and the Queen."
Non-book readers may have entirely
missed him admiring Rhaenyra at the hunt
or bumping into her on the Street of Silk.
"And who might you be running from now?"
"Sir Harwin."
"Princess."
But after the 10-year time jump, we can
tell from pretty obvious context clues
that Harwin and Rhaenyra are very fond of
each other and have had a relationship for
most of the previous decade. He's
the real father of her three boys,
and is as doting a family man as
he can be under the circumstances.
He tells his own father in response to rumors,
"You have your honor and I have mine." That
honor compels him to defend Rhaenyra and her sons
against Criston and his insults by way of a good,
strong punch. Unfortunately, this costs him
his job, and, soon after, his life. When they
say their goodbyes, he and Rhaenyra make eyes at
each other, but alas, "Breakbones," as he's known,
must leave the princess and princes without so
much as a goodbye kiss. This irritated fans,
who might have liked a positive scene of physical
contact after so many portrayals of assault and
abuse. Failing that, fans of Harwin just wish
he could've stuck around a little longer.
Episode 7 of Season 1, "Driftmark," sent
fans into a tizzy. But they weren't upset
by violence or cruelty — they were bothered by
the lighting. "Driftmark" opens with Laena's
twilit funeral. After the sun goes down,
Daemon and Rhaenyra consummate their 15
years of flirtation on the beach, while
Aemond sneaks out to test drive Vhagar.
"Vhagar is my mother's dragon."
"Your mother's dead. And
Vhagar has a new rider now."
In the aftermath, Aemond instigates
a brawl and loses an eye.
House of the Dragon fans complained that
they couldn't see what was going on,
due to the episode's extremely dim lighting.
Many compared the installment to the infamous
Season 8 Game of Thrones episode "The
Long Night." The long-awaited Battle of
Winterfell underwhelmed audiences,
despite its record-breaking scale,
because everything was so darn dark. When fans
expressed their outrage that this happened again
with "Driftmark," the show defended the
lighting as a purposeful artistic choice.
Since House of the Dragon takes place in a
world without electricity, a certain dimness
is understandable. But many fans believe this nod
to authenticity interrupts basic storytelling.
While Daemon, Criston, and even Otto age
well from episode to episode, King Viserys
looks more and more worse for the wear. But to
everyone's surprise, he is at his most heroic
when he's at his most decrepit in Episode 8,
"The Lord of the Tides." George R. R. Martin
told actor Paddy Considine that he prefers his
take on the character to his own, comparing
Considine's Viserys to King Lear. Fans agreed,
championing Viserys' last stand for his daughter
and lamenting his final family dinner. Then comes
the misunderstanding to end all misunderstandings.
With his final breath, the withered king
thinks he's continuing a life-or-death
conversation with his daughter, when really,
he's talking to his wife. He means to tell
Rhaenyra that he believes in Aegon's dream,
and, what's more, he believes the Prince
That Was Promised will come from her line.
"To unite the realm. Against
the cold. And the dark."
But Alicent wrongfully interprets these
phrases to mean that he wants their son
Aegon to succeed him. Instead of setting
things right, Viserys messes everything up,
just when he was finally ruling the realm and
his family with strength and solidity. Book
readers were particularly taken aback by this
development. In Fire & Blood, Otto and Alicent
usurp the throne just because they want to.
This show-invented ending completely changes
the reason the Dance of the Dragons starts at all,
which many fans find unnecessary and frustrating.
The drama that's been building up all
season comes to a head in Episode 9,
"The Green Council," when the Greens seize
power. It takes a lot of objectionable behavior
to pull off this coup. Criston brutally kills
Lord Beesbury during a small council meeting.
Otto seeks to assassinate the other half of
Viserys' family. The servants are imprisoned,
and Rhaenys is kept captive in her room. We
find out that Aegon II not only has myriad
bastards running around Flea Bottom, he
spends his spare time at child fighting
pits. Oh, and Meleys kills hundreds of
commoners while escaping the Dragonpit.
But what really upsets viewers is the price
Larys puts on his information. Alicent's
personal Master of Whisperers approaches her
with some intel concerning her father. Before
he spills the beans, he wants something
in return. Alicent takes off her shoes.
When that doesn't produce the desired
result, she removes her stockings. This
all happens without a word being spoken
between them, which is proof enough that
it's happened before. She turns her head as
Larys enjoys the sight of her naked feet.
Larys is exploiting Alicent, and Alicent
knows it — but there's nothing she can
do. This squirmy scene is vintage Game of
Thrones: It's out of left field, gross,
and meant to shock us. Indeed, fans couldn't
stop talking about this moment after "The
Green Council" aired. Even diehard Rhaenyra fans
can't help but feel for the queen in this moment.
Twins Jaime and Cersei Lannisters'
long-term relationship is at the
heart of their dysfunction on Game
of Thrones. But both the creators
and fans of House of the Dragon are more on
board with Daemon and Rhaenyra's romance,
though they're uncle and niece. Maybe the
fact that it's a Targaryen tradition makes
them okay with it. Maybe it's just that Matt
Smith has chemistry with everybody. Maybe it's
that once they exchange their very particular
marriage vows, Daemon and Rhaenyra seem pretty
happy together. Whatever the reason, Season
1 got many to root for this uncommon couple.
So viewers were understandably shaken by the
moment Daemon grabs his wife by the throat
in Episode 10, "The Black Queen." Rhaenyra is
considering Alicent's terms. She feels Viserys
tasked her with preparing for the coming war
in the North and holding the realm together;
whether she sits on the Iron Throne
while doing that is of less consequence.
She confides this in Daemon, thinking he's
been let in on the secret of Aegon's dream.
"This secret has been passed from
king to heir since Aegon's time."
But he hasn't. Daemon seems to become
enraged by the thought that Rhaenyra
might be a cautious and omen-savvy
ruler, like her father was. He grows
even angrier when he realizes Viserys
didn't trust him with this information.
"Daemon was not made to wear the crown,
but I believe that you were."
Though we've seen Daemon react
impulsively on several occasions,
many viewers felt this abuse was out of
character. Notably, this scene doesn't occur
in Fire & Blood. Daemon isn't a hero and isn't
even a good husband to Rhaenyra in the book,
but this moment still felt like a
bridge too far to plenty of fans.